dann nämlich die popstars oder wieder
zeit was geht ab und jetzt willkommen
bei einem neuen video apropos klatschen
das ist heute wieder ganz wichtig da
wollte ich hoffe natürlich geht es gut
und auch danke vor drei vier tagen kam
das video wo wir songs erwarten haben
[Musik]
da habe ich zusammen mit den lobbys
musik erraten und das video ist echt
richtig gut angekommen und ich habe mir
gedacht hey
eigentlich könnte man das noch mal
machen das wird sicherlich auch noch mal
geben wir haben uns heute was anders
überlege ich habe heute marie dabei es
geht ja auch und hinter der kamera ist
noch juni nicht zeigen und da hinten in
der ecke ist eine box die ziemlich laut
ist noch mal kurz guten musikern guten
musik
[Musik]
und ihr habt ja wahrscheinlich habe ich
schon gelesen heute geht es nicht
einfach nur um musik heute geht es um
stimmen
ich habe das ganze noch nie gesehen
zumindest oder gezwungen wo man stimmen
erreichen oder genau youtuber infos in
drei sekunden erraten oder soll ja auch
schon mal gesehen aber wir machen als
heute mit bekannten stimmen wenn es ganz
einfach wenn du die stimme kannst du
dann hast du drei sekunden zeit den
namen zu sagen schaffst du es nicht in
drei sekunden geht der punkt sozusagen
nicht an mich direkt erreichen
punktgenau
ich will gar nicht eingeladen das ist
auf jeden fall ein fed noch nach oben da
und wir fangen an mit der ersten show
ausgesucht
ja okay okay wir fangen an das sagte sie
zumal junge kannst du mal zur tank
gefahren ross von der willigen flirten
tetra pak holen
stefan raab ich dachte ich dachte halt
am anfang es wäre wirklich irgendwie aus
ist ja von herrn pfarrer oder so das war
wohl ein punkt für mich also ist nicht
echt an
wir machen das ganze bis 10 so leute
erste runde gegen albin
und wir machen weiter möchte runde
nummer 21 staaten hier schwimmen bereit
ach ja aber du hast dass er nur da
anerkannt und mittags also das zeit-
oder ja okay ich schwöre dir ja ich habe
ehrlich gedacht wir müssen uns
gegenseitig raus und hab ich auch nach
bundestag katze eigentlich ganz gut aus
ja eins zu eins ganz wichtig ihr könnt
natürlich auch mit raten obwohl in drei
sekunden ist das ziemlich schwer und
hatte ich mich selbst auch die gleiche
stimme wie benjamin blümchen
nein ich habe letztens irgendwann mal
spongebob geguckt und da ist mir
aufgefallen dass der jetzt eine neue
stimme und patrick auch die haben alle
neue stimmen
ich bin auch nicht
was ist das jetzt hier für eine serie
okay es geht weiter leicht irgendwie
kasten wäre wenn die story als in den
vorjahren
das war schon beim skating spikes sagen
doch der krieg den abzug noch so könne
camel aber ich hätte den jetzt an der
stimme und jetzt haben wir nehmen den
rauch hättet ihr das gewusst also ich
nicht also nur mit dem schiff so leute
es steht immer noch 1 1 und wir kommen
zur nächsten runde scheint bei jetzt in
die kommentare was glaubt ihr wer
gewinnt machen oder alex was glaubst du
ich natürlich wenn ich jetzt sagen okay
das stimmt dann glaube ich auch dass ich
gewinne aber ich werde sicherlich auch
zu hause noch mal also komm doch mit auf
eine kulinarische reise nach tunesien
der heimat und ich habe untergebracht
[Applaus]
und ich habe sehr viel spaß verliehen
werden ich mache aber noch die lage
so wird auch jedes mal hat das haus lief
und ich hab fast noch nie wieder welche
endlich darauf gekommen
also ich kann nur die stimme ich dir
gedacht
tunesien hat gedachte tunesien wer kennt
das nicht haben die leute wollen immer
zwischendrin ich scheiße jetzt fällt mir
nicht ein
aber ich könnte die stimme direktor ist
ein muslim annika nicht die stimme auch
bei mir ist das nicht eigentlich hat es
zum beispiel weiter lenken richtig
hoffen wir bei diesem video auch über
100000 auch nach oben aus scheiße man
sieht den supreme feuerlöscher gar nicht
im hintergrund jetzt schon besser
so leute da ist kommen wir zur runde
nummer weil wir einfach noch mal sechs
meinetwegen mir auch egal
wir stehen müssen
eigentlich also zumindest eine chance
machen wir mal weiter so geben da hab
ich noch mal sagen
toni kroos der drei punkte ich weiß es
nicht junge beste bekannt sind
ich habe erst gedacht wirklich machen
wir danach nicht so hey warum ist es so
schwer man kennt die stimme aber man
weiß nicht zu wem gehört denn hätte ich
erkannt also ich habe jetzt wieder null
punkte und du hast die saison ist fliege
kann ja gar nicht klatschen
ganzen platz wegnimmt energie und sagen
es hat schon die doktoren frank von uns
hier rennen ihre studie deutsche endlich
finden um euch auch die neue kollektion
zu zeigen und die noch auf der passieren
also doch sie hat ist jetzt ja schon so
lange wie in jedem jahr nämlich die pop
up store ab oder wieder salz doch auch
pop up stores shoe energie bee pubs sind
richtig schlecht und so das 2 1 ich
dachte auch anfang her wer ist das denn
jetzt verliert ministerin würde ich
sofort erkennen glaube ich und wie
willst du mehr kennen man ja auch sofort
ja aber da gibt es hätte ich eigentlich
auch gedacht dass ich wegen schlusswort
erkennen dazu einzelner kommen machen
wir als erstes vier punkte doch die
leute runde nummer es war auch wirklich
kommt ist wo er seine angst auslösen so
ergebnis
new york
wir haben einen zwischenstand von 3 2 1
für dich kommen mache aber es fünf oder
ok jetzt jetzt jetzt punkte ich wieder
präsentiert sich also für den iren
heroin kokain turner
doch das ist dieses interview bei joiz
genau ich weiß ich werde euch moneyball
kennen das ist auf jeden fall ein
deutscher rapper an den österreichischen
rapper und er ist in seine sendung
gegangen die sich speziell eigentlich an
kinder gerichtet oder jugendliche und
halt gibt es einen von drogen erzähle
hat diese komplett verabschiedet
moderatorin und ich finds halt es witzig
so aber ich weiß nicht ob ihr 40 aber
ich schon deswegen ist mir eingefallen
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
verfolgungsjagd bis fünf jetzt ok mache
ist ein zwei punkte und dann hat sich
das gelegt weiß ja das war ja ein
objektiv guter ja also dann hätte ich
auch nicht gesund übrigens verlierer
muss wohnung sommer machen
nein aber welche wonne ist das jetzt
zehnte schon wunder nummer 10
darauf warte ich muss kurz wieder
konzentrieren den kennst du aber ja klar
du kannst du jetzt nicht sagen dass das
ein bisschen wenn du das so schnell wie
sich noch irgendwas sagen wenn du es
schnell mal stimme ich bin nicht gut
[Musik]
der hat mir der hat mit dartpfeilen nach
gemacht dass hier von mir nach gemacht
mit den daten alles gut
ja ja hier werde ich jetzt den punkt
mache da habe ich gewonnen und wenn du
den punkt macht dann hat noch keiner
ich kann ja mal so tun als er abonniert
damit locker ich hab noch nicht mal
dann allerdings das irgendwen abonnieren
kann welche habt ihr mich dann schon
lange abonniert das kleine mädchen
einfach unten auf den abonnieren -button
drücken ich glaube 51 prozent von meinen
zuschauern haben mich bis jetzt
abonnieren
das kann ich ja sehen ist auch gar kein
aufwand bei mir ist das sogar kostenlos
ja ihr können kostenlos abonnieren
die glocke aktivieren und krieg dann
immer sofort nachlegen wenn ein neues
video wie zum beispiel dieses besonders
coole video online ist das was hätte hat
aber noch nicht gesprochen
das war doch wo sie oder er hätte ich
auch drauf kommen können also 44 1 punkt
entscheidet wer mit dem match weil das
heißt wer den nächsten punkt macht
gewinnt stimme erwarten alle alex w und
ich bin mal gespannt sowohl für uns ist
entschieden hat auf der denker und
betreibt 21
ja ja ich habe sofort erkannt ich musste
früher mit meinen eltern immer wer wird
millionär gucken mir war eigentlich von
vornherein klar dass das heute ein ganz
einfaches spiel wird und ich den punkt
nach hause fahren werde war natürlich
nur ein schnitzel
ich hoffe dass wieder durchgefallen
abonniere nicht vergessen gibt noch nach
oben für noch ein paar sterne auch von
juden ins koma und ab und von marie
zweites mal hier kurz eingeblendet oder
in der video beschreibung und wir sehen
uns morgen wieder und übermorgen will
etwas sagen oder so
[Musik]